[MUSIC PLAYING]
POORNIMA VIJAYASHANKER: Hi,
I'm Poornima Vijayashanker,
the founder of Femgineer.
Femgineer is an
education company
where we help techies,
like yourselves,
level up in your careers and
build products and companies.
Now, like many of you, I got my
start as a software engineer.
I was heads down, writing
code, shipping product,
putting in long
hours, secretly hoping
that someone would
notice all my effort
and let me pick the projects
I wanted and get promoted.
But, unfortunately,
despite all my long hours,
I got passed up for
promotions and projects.
So then I thought,
you know what?
I'll just put in more hours.
I'll learn to write more code.
I'll learn a new programming
language, and that'll help.
But it didn't.
In fact, it only
made matters worse.
And that's when I realized
what I needed to do.
I needed to speak up.
But "speaking up," you know,
it sounds so self-promotional.
It sounds like you only care
about what you're working on.
And, you know, why
would anybody care
about what you're working
on when all they care about
is the end goal
or the end result?
It's scary to think about.
People might judge you.
They might wonder, you
know, who are you to speak?
Especially if you're only a
couple years into your career.
You might be thinking,
you know, I've only
been coding for two weeks, two
months, or two years, or two
decades.
Or, I'm new to a role.
I'm not exactly an expert.
Why would anybody care
about what I have to say?
I don't know, you know,
what to talk about.
And so often we think, you
know, we're just not an expert,
we might as well keep our
mouth shut because it's
too self-promotional.
But I discovered a way in which
I could speak up for myself
and showcase my
worth authentically.
And that was by
teaching people--
teaching them about
the work I was doing,
the results I was
getting, and giving them
a step-by-step process to
replicate it, because there's
always somebody out there who's
a beginner, who wants to learn,
just like what you went through.
And by showcasing your work
and teaching them, they care.
And they can
actually learn a lot.
So it's actually a
very effective form
of learning to come out and hear
you speak, because the stories
that you share are repeatable.
And they're memorable.
And for many people, that's
what they care about,
not just sitting at
home and reading a book
or doing a Google search--
no offense to our host.
They're coming out
to hear you speak.
And what they want to
know from all of you is,
you know, what were
your experiences?
What were your perspectives
on a project, or even learning
how to build a
product or learning
a new language or a framework?
And oftentimes even
some of those moments
we have where we
feel like, oh, it
took me years to
learn how to code,
or it took me months to
get through to my team,
or it took me years to
shape a product, you know,
all those moments
that we think are
failures are actually really
valuable for other people
to hear.
Because think about it this way.
Those years of
effort you put in,
all those gotcha
moments you had,
all those things that you wished
you could have done better,
well, now they are
treasures for other people.
You're going to help them
fast track their learning,
and that's really valuable.
They want to know that.
They want to accelerate
their career,
and you're helping
them to do it.
So in the end, it's
an authentic way
of showcasing all the hard
work that you've done.
Now, you might be wondering,
how do you do this, right?
So Karen Catlin,
my co-author, and I
have come up with
the Inventory Method.
And the way that the Inventory
Method works is you're
going to take stock of all
the projects you've done
over the last 3 to 12 months.
The reason we say 3
to 12 is because it's
what's freshest in your mind.
And since we're in tech and
things move pretty quickly,
it's also what's most relevant.
Now, as you take
stock, you'll notice
some themes start to emerge.
And these themes can then
be crafted into a topic.
And then if you're worried
about what people think,
well, you can share the
topic with your coworkers,
your teammates, and your
friends or people who you think
are going to be the audience.
And when you do this,
you'll notice a few things
start to emerge.
Let me give you an example.
For myself, when I
was getting started,
I decided that I wanted to
speak at a local conference.
I signed up, and I was about
two years into my career.
I was the founding
engineer of Mint.com,
and I thought, why
would anybody want
to hear what I have to say?
But it turns out it
was really valuable
for me to share my experience
building a prototype,
launching it, and scaling it.
And as a result,
people came out.
They heard me speak.
They wanted to
come work at Mint.
And a lot of people saw
me and thought, wow,
I want to learn from this woman.
She's a go-to resource
for startups, engineering,
and entrepreneurship.
So realize that when you
speak, opportunities emerge
and you're making a
difference, both in your life
and your career,
but someone else's.
You're helping them fast
track their learning.
If you've enjoyed
this and enjoyed
learning about the method,
like Inventory Method,
we've got a lot of
other great techniques
for you in our
latest book "Present!
A Techie's Guide to
Public Speaking."
Come by our booth
and pick up a copy.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]